we're at tennis today for the handover  to the RNLI of our life garden services  this is a major step forward for Team  bridge and Tim with and Dawlish in  particular because the RNLI are a  national organization and they have the  ability and the training to provide a  very high standard of service so we are  going to be able to provide an improved  service for all our residents and  visitors and we're also as a result of  this going to be able to provide the  lifeguards themselves with training  which will provide them with a career  path the RNLI are nationally and  internationally renowned for the quality  of their training and of the service  that they provide and this will be a  great enhancement to our facilities here  in ten bridge